[Musik]
was machen sie hier
ja ich schaue mir das ganze mal an ich
muss sagen ich habe ein bisschen angst
auch vor künstlicher intelligenz
intelligenz generell oder auch heute die
ganze nein ich rede ja mit ihnen
das muss wieder politik moment machen
dass er mit der digitalisierung so
hinterher hängen
das ist ja wahrscheinlich der masterplan
oder wir verpassen den anschluss und
alle arbeitsplätze sind gerettet
das genial das wäre echt interessante
gedanke hier nehmen sie das kompliment
machen
danke dass ich so selten komplimente ja
aber das wäre doch sympathisch sie
stehen morgens auf der toaster spricht
mit ihnen
das ist ein paar anzuschreien also keine
toaster redet mir was ist daran schön
dass eine alptraum
hier soll wieder soll das tust du sollst
mir reden ich bin morgens schlecht drauf
der soll einfach das scheiß trost machen
es kommt drauf an ob sie einsam sind
oder nicht ja so ein bisschen
konversation also der toast ist
psychologisch geschult glauben sie dass
künstliche intelligenz uns alle töten
oder ist sie gar nicht so schlau
das kommt auch den programmierer darauf
an
also wenn ich da so ein bisschen so
einen terroristen hinten dran setzen
habe und der sagt okay ich noch machen
wir die ganze menschheit nieder
wir haben eine variante was glauben sie
werden maschinen in zukunft nie können
hier fehlen gefühle
das ist die falsche antwort maschinen
werden in zukunft niemals spd politiker
werden weil dafür denkt maschinen viel
zu logisch darstellen wollen ist eine
robotik lösung die schnecken bekämpft im
ackerbau und zwar sollen die detektiert
werden für den roboter sichtbar gemacht
werden segmentiert werden und hinten
sollen die schnecken den free kassiert
werden also klein gemacht werden
ach guck mal der ist ja süß hier hallo
was hast du denn vor
wird die die arbeiterpartei dann
umbenannt in arbeitslosen partei wenn
die maschine alle arbeitsplätze gelegt
haben
also wir sehen ja dass arbeitsplätze
wegfallen andere entstehen also leute
die sie zum beispiel das ist ja nach wie
vor geben also stellen sie sich noch vor
da stünde jetzt eine sehr gut aussehende
roboter vor mir dem würde ich ja nicht
die gleichen antworten geben also ich
finde ich gut aussehend habe ich das
habe ich das richtig
im gegenteil würde sicherlich den
roboter ihnen nachbilden damit man 1 1 0
0 0 1 1 1
0 0 1 0 1 0 0 0 1 1 1 1 0 0 0 1 1 1 sie
sind uns aber wir sind ein roboter wird
haben sie keine angst vor künstlicher
intelligenz
nein überhaupt nicht aber sie wird uns
alle töten das wissen sie schon ja
früher oder später aber bis dahin noch
eine schöne zeit
ok so kommen dass sich aussehen also
auch anfangen hatte ich schon angst dass
wir alle durch roboter ersetzt werden
aber nach diesem gipfel muss ich ganz
klar sagen alles ist gut machen sie sich
keine sorgen und damit zurück ins studio
[Musik]